to tech billionaires are clashing over
the future of artificial intelligence
Tesla co-founder Elon Musk warned this
lot that AI is a fundamental risk to the
existence of human civilization I keep
so much sounding lis long belt but you
know until people see like robots going
down the street killing people like they
don't know how to react you know because
it seems so ethereal
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg criticized
those comments without using must name
during a Facebook live broadcast from
his backyard and I think that people who
are naysayers and kind of try to drum up
these doomsday scenarios are I just I
don't understand it I think it's it's
it's really negative and in some ways I
actually think it's it's pretty
irresponsible you know I must fired back
yesterday in a tweet he said quote I've
talked to mark about this his
understanding of the subject is limited
ouch
yes take that money yeah neither
Facebook nor Tesla responded to a
request for comment robert sapien is
editor of Fast Company magazine good
morning good morning morning this is not
a new debate among people who look at a
yawn yes the machines are coming
together yes could they both be right I
think they're both right and they're
both wrong listen when you talk about AI
people use a lot of words for this
artificial intelligence machine learning
cognitive computing we use different
words to describe the same thing
sometimes we use the same words to
describe different things all this gets
gets confusing in this way when new
technology comes along people get
anxious about it but lay out what Elon
some of you on Musk's concerns are
because I think they're legitimate his
concerns are that in the long run
there's going to be some intelligence
that could crash systems we could have
wars that would be started it's it's a
it's a very doomsday oriented scenario
you you go back though and in history
right you go back to the 1880s and you
had Thomas Edison and George George
Westinghouse fighting over the
development of the electrical system
right because electrocution was going to
kill people so these things always
happen in the in the long lens of
history technology has always improved
the human condition the question is
there's noise between here and there and
how do we manage
that situation and that's what musk is
really pointing to he believes that we
need more oversight and some kind of
regulatory apparatus to make sure
technology and AI develops and the other
people who believe will heal on does
like Bill Gates and some others have
said there is a warning unless we have
regulation and monitoring unless there's
some way to do it now Mark Zuckerberg
believes that one of the things he loves
about technology and software is you can
constantly improve it so if there's a
problem we'll fix it
that sort of Mark's approach to things
and and that's kind of part of where
their clash comes about is their world
view about this so you don't think that
it this is just two billionaires who are
playing a game of whose is bigger
well you know I think they have a clear
difference of opinion that they're both
enjoying enjoying using but I do think
there is a philosophical point of it
there that's that's specifically
different and and again both of their
businesses rely on AI Musk's as much as
Zuckerberg right autonomous driving
self-driving cars that is artificial
intelligence a version of it so and so
they they both are invested in it they
both know it and the genie is not going
back in the bottle yeah and they're not
gonna happen they're both two guys who
have a healthy appraisal of their own
intelligence there's no question don't
lack for confidence but when you look at
the long lens of history when it comes
to technology what do you see III don't
see that that technology makes our world
worse there's a lot of noise there's a
lot of dislocation as I say in this
transition right but in the lens of
history glossing over what are things
we're glossing over what are some of you
on Musk's concerns which is that
computers don't make moral decisions and
that humans make moral decisions that's
part of his concern is that you right am
i right yes but I think the risks with
AI are as much about what individuals
and people and organizations and and
unintended consequences of this
technology as much as what the machines
might decide to do wrong because I said
in the book can be right you know in the
long term without monitoring it is
possible Elon is right no the people
recognize this that you can have a bunch
of robots that are smarter than a bunch
of humans and it would that again
decision for a long way could right
things that would be we're a long way
from those places remember that Elon
Musk is the guy who wants to you know
have us live on another planet
right and and that may happen but it's a
long time until that happens what do we
put in place between here and there to
make sure that this technology is used
in an effective way and that's really
what Elon is trying to encourage us to
think of no there's really smart guys
that were very successful and I think
are both raising very valid points yeah
thank you Robert great to have you here
good to have you here at the table
always